like I I went to like a pickup boot camp  once and it's basically where they teach  guys how to get laid and so I could see  I could see the uh the extremes it was  really interesting it was kind of like  like seeing what they teach the boys  they have them here too yeah yeah  um it's it's a very big kids  no it's a really big Community like they  they pay thousands of dollars to fly  into a city yeah and and learn from guys  that know how to get laid how to get  laid okay  because that's how that's how like  lonely they are but because they they  don't even know what it's like to have a  girl like look at them and be in they  don't even know what it's like to have a  girl excited to talk to them